The Joe Rogan Experience
um I'm so excited to be here with you
today yeah this is our first podcast
coming out as our true selves we're
furry yeah we've been holding it in
Forever This is my true identity uh and
you know what it's just eats me alive to
not tell how we met at a furry con
laughs
well we didn't know that we met there
remember well yeah I didn't know who you
were for a long time yeah we didn't know
I'm like oh my God you're meow meow dude
it blew my mind I mean to me that is
proof we're in a simulation
um because what are the odds they're not
good
what are the odds man the odds are also
not good that I'm gonna keep this
[__] helmet on oh my God I'm sweating
not good for me I'm not keeping this on
dude I could barely breathe how do they
do it I don't know they [__] with these
things on how do you [__] with this song
They're Heroes
Heroes
total respect for furries respect for
the furry community look I got the feet
on and everything it's like Bikram
[__]
yeah it's very hot in here if you can
[__] with this on you're an American
hero yeah that's how I feel
David Coggins needs to put on one of
these things and [__] for an hour he
should yeah you think you're so cool
running for A Thousand Miles how about
[__] for four and a half minutes with
this one
I can't [__] for four and a half minutes
without it on but this is like sprinting
uphill this is
really brutal and just thinking about
padding around a Ramada in one of these
things I get it
from Orlando Orlando
I get it when I put it on I get it I
know why they do it
I don't know why all of them do it wait
why do you think they do it I think they
do it because it offers you an anonymity
that is impossible any other way right
and it turns you into a your image the
visual that people get of you is this
adorable cute
mascot right everybody loves a mascot
the mascot is literally there to pump
everybody up and yay and they don't talk
and everybody loves them yeah right
people at Disneyland same thing wait
they don't talk no
they don't talk like if you meet goofy
goofy doesn't say jack [__] to you
we went to Goofy's Kitchen goofy doesn't
talk
yeah it's like I can't I can't do it oh
my God
oh it's so hard to breathe it's so hard
to breathe horrible how about those
[__] people that work at Disneyland
that wear these things and they walk
around in the heat in the summer
respect to them dude those Disneyland
like the people who do this at
Disneyland Heroes they party I heard I
heard it's like insane when they get off
work like they [__] party first of
all it's not even their fault their
brains have been cooked all day do you
know what kind of effect that must have
oh my God cognitive function dude like
while we're bitching because they made
us wear masks on planes they're going
around in a hot box I bet they made them
wear a mask under their stupid mask
guarantee it I bet they guarantee it
everything
dorks you had a mask up in your in your
goofy outfit
though these are dope dude these are
incredible and it's kind of sad that we
can't we're [__] of all the uh of all
the costumes we've worn yeah this I
think this is the least time we've spent
yeah even the hoods but I was like
almost like hyperventilating in there
dude I was panicking
you can see this awful wall yeah it's
terrible but I do don't you get it
though if you were like a very
tortured socially awkward person your
life has just been a mess but you are
for whatever reason attracted sexually
to the idea of it or maybe not even
actually maybe just attracted the idea
of it but then you do it and you just
you get to be not just innocuous not
just like someone that doesn't get like
someone gets picked on not just not that
but instead attractive you're this
adorable thing you're adorable like hey
and people want they come up to you with
a different energy dude I've seen some
really hot furry porn like I've seen
some incredible furry people what's the
worst furry Point have you ever seen
something like God you guys aren't even
trying I those those are still shots
usually like weird Polaroids and stuff
of like like so and generally those are
like solo furries who are banging a
stuffed animal right
that sucks that's not cool that's not
cool but so they do they put a
flashlight in a stuffed animal no
they're not that advanced just rip a
hole of course in the [__] thing's
butt and just like oh leave their
crusted jizz on it as some work of
achievement or something really bad oh
really bad human beings are so weird in
so many ways yes in so many ways but
it's like it's so funny it's like media
like Norman Rockwell paintings there's
this like image of us that we are when
we're at our best the family dinner
table in a 1980s movie yeah yeah you
know that's us we're we're at our best
everyone's getting along how's school
going Junior yeah Junior's doing great
but the reality is like there's no
license to get a person you don't have a
license to become pregnant you don't you
don't have to go through any
qualification processes it's literally
the most important thing for the future
of the human race yeah that people who
have children and raise those those
children are capable of doing it you're
capable of raising a well-adjusted
person yeah like any person growing up
as a a human being today baby to grown
up like you're born today and you've got
to become a grown-up in this [__]
Wacky World yeah good luck being normal
oh my God